[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i can't tell you no no no i already know
what you're going to bring up it's fine
i can talk about it
but i have to protect the the entity
itself okay
that's fine
what is it is um he's how many days now
15 days 15 days of no pornography
wow wow wait how about how bad was your
problem steve
it wasn't that it was
bad bad it was that i didn't like i
didn't like what
pornography was doing to my mind sure
sure because i realized
i mean because you know we're messed up
i mean i'm not blaming him
he definitely i know we have nothing to
do i know i know but you you
you don't quote me but i just remember
it was a progressive thing as far as i
remember younger
this is before the internet like him
having like a dvd
he had a whole like collection of them
and i would take one or two and then
how many three you
[Laughter]
he could have filled up like an amoeba
record like
a whole store yeah
you know those one of those booklets
you know those booklets where you put
cds
well you know those boys those big black
thick booklets like that
he had hundreds of those just
collections
like the beatles collections collections
collections
yeah just collect collectors just
failed failed sorry but the rest hey but
but steve steve let me ask you though
what was the so what what was the reason
that you quit what was this moment
well i realized that it it affected just
my like my relationship sex life yeah or
just it just kind of like
it not only desensitized me like as far
as
because i noticed too like when i was
like like i would be on pornhub or x
videos
my searches would be a little bit more
further like going kind of outside the
box you know like what
give us an example well it started with
just like pov doggy or
you know something like that or you know
cream pie or you know yeah just like
your
i don't know if that's standard that is
that's right okay
but then it started going into like
crack head
cream pie
[Laughter]
so
[Laughter]
i found a therapist a korean guy
dr choi yeah and i wanted to
we had fun doing my dream um
i wrote down the dream the day the night
before yesterday yeah
i want you to read it off there's i just
doubt i want you to analyze um just the
notes that i
had about my dream they read it out loud
into the mic
dream number one tunnel i had to walk
through
on the ground were centipedes
and even scorpions got to a luxury
school it's because this has got to a
luxury high school
walked into men's shower
notice that the male females were
combined
what you walked through a men's shower
notice that the male and females were
combined
they were like genetically or like
mutated
two different sexes uh
showered all alone in the dark
i had an apartment
like a micro home room
a
[Laughter]
does anyone know what happened over the
weekend does it okay
what are you going to say before we even
get up i might stop the biggest thing
all right well i'm stopping you what
that has no
business in in this podcast anymore i
feel like it's my right to tell this
story it's my story to tell guess why
what you guys cuz i didn't [ __ ] put
your poop in a doggy bag didn't i
whoa it's my story now as
if i have to do the cleanup it's my
story to tell
i have to know the story now please tell
me
tell us bobby please tell me your story
you tell him
so i get a phone call i get a phone call
he's coming home from
from warner brothers and i got a frantic
phone call he's like
that's that's not something's so bad oh
yeah he went to terry he
is mexican which is great food by the
way no there's a new one on
and i get a phone call and he's like
babe something really bad just happened
in my head the first thing is like oh my
god he's finally run over somebody
and like that's what happened because of
his driving yeah because he's a wild
rider
dude his driving's insane yeah so
then i was like [ __ ] what happened
and he's like i need help i'm downstairs
in the garage
and there's poo everywhere
and i'm like how is there poo everywhere
it turns out that he was on the freeway
on route to come home
stuck in traffic couldn't make it out of
the exit
pulled over into the side of the freeway
climbed over into the back seat
and took [ __ ] in the back seat
do you like dad that's something dad
you
i can't believe it you're just like dead
man
this look exactly what dad would do let
me tell you this story
all the time my dad was driving
he used to drive this van because he put
uh
his merchandise in it and then he was
on some kind of freeway or highway and
he couldn't
stop either but he did it on a paper
plate at least
he did it right on the seat disgusting
man
and then he comes he comes running
upstairs you're a goddamn
animal man you need help bro and can i
tell you what happened
afterwards he's a beast so he tells
oh he comes up and i see his butt as he
runs into the bathroom and it's just
diarrhea all over his pants so then i'm
thinking
he couldn't even take his [ __ ] pants
off it's just
his [ __ ] it's his health
no we need
[Music]
and then i said okay fine i'll take it
to the car wash in the morning but i was
like you know what i'm not gonna do it
i'm gonna have jenna do it
because you know jenna needs the money
and i so i told her you better give her
500
she came in in a hazmat suit she i swear
to god she came in fully suited up
but then he goes it was fifty dollars
[Laughter]
dude 50.
it was 50.
oh lord and then he said he said i tried
to
i tried to clean it with a spray as best
as i could
so jenna should be fine dry so jenna
basically
had but then that's not the worst part
on the way there oh no
on the way there jenna checked the back
seat because she was like something
smells really bad are you sure that he
cleaned it with spray
and she goes back there and there's two
big turds that kind of just
roll have been rolling around in the
back seat camouflaged into this yeah
so she then has to she then had she
calls me she's like oh my god i don't
know what to do but there's still poo
rolling around back there
and so i she had to pick it up she had
to use her hand she had to
raw hand it i'm worried about his health
there's so much he's going to get a
colonoscopy there's so much meat
korean barbecue and just meat that
hasn't digested
i know his body i am his brother he's
nuts
you're my top oh i'm like dove you're my
kid oh okay yeah yeah why
why are you mic'd up if you were miked
up you don't have to use that
no i'm not like yeah i know but
if you were to be mic'd up this is eb
show okay
this is a stevie wiebe show this is not
dvd asa or tiger
i understand so i don't know so i'm i'm
okay you're okay okay you're in my
mannequin
yeah okay so this is a dream i had last
night
stevie weeby's show bad dream it's a bad
dream all right
how about this song how about this i
would read this right yeah yeah but
you don't laugh what you don't laugh
oh is this like the contest okay i just
i just don't want you to laugh at
yourself
this was a mistake huh no i love you
okay i love so sorry okay
ready bad dream okay kidnapped by
white mom she was a young mother
trailer trashy but had skate style
my legs was cut off and put back on
upper left side i thought babe okay i'm
sorry i didn't know if you were because
i couldn't read whatever you just said
there yeah
all right so upper left eye middle
stitches
around old thigh
she had a son plus one
who was the other person
rode in front seat with two
two kids and mom
had to take a picture of her son's
skateboard
they didn't have a house it's slapped by
two
lake tourist area
isn't it
[Music]
oh god that's so dumb
i don't know man i mean my question is
this
i don't know might if somebody ever
cut off my leg right and then stitch it
back up with metal stitches
yeah i don't yeah but i don't know if i
would be at that incline to
film the skateboarding well why would
you want to film
do you agree kobe do you agree
what is your problem right now dude i
don't know turn the music down
your attitude right now [ __ ] you dude
what do you mean with your attitude
right now
what do you mean we asked you to be a
part of this group and now you're having
an attitude
what are you talking about you were like
if i don't get a red bull you're not
gonna come oh no
how dare you dude i've i filmed two uh
podcasts yesterday myself oh wow yeah
whoa
well relax and my patreon is struggling
severely severely why are you gonna have
him red zoned from many
and i talked to my therapist about it
yeah and i realized
i can't i can't it's like apples and
oranges i he's got decades on me
mm-hmm i just started driving i know
i know it's just my frustration of i'm
trying to like at least
be self-sustainable too that's all you
will be
that's all yeah yeah and so it's just
frustrating that like because i spend a
lot of time on my patreon
yeah we should just why am i even do it
like so you know what you should spend
time on what
brushing your teeth because
when i got in the car your breath was
like chernobyl dude
do you remember uh twilight zone
the movie yeah dude
the movie they actually did a movie yeah
i saw the [ __ ] movie
now do you remember like when john
lithgow or the plane the wing
yeah a little creature in there yeah on
the and he thought it was going crazy
can i tell you a little story about that
movie though yeah what happened in real
life in that movie right
no one one of the leads of the movie
and two kid actresses actor and actors
of kids
yeah the first week of shooting
there was a helicopter scene where a
helicopter lands
it crashes yeah it killed the lead
yeah and the two lead kids in it
decapitated them
right in real life yeah really and they
kept shooting
the show must go on man oh is it the one
the episode where it's like the old
people are like turn to kids at the end
at that
that no i don't i don't know what it was
i think they cut the scene they're not
gonna put the [ __ ] scene
they probably cut that scene in the
movie
do you remember the episode it's called
it's a good life
and there's a school teacher who drives
into this town
and she meets this kid on a bike
and then the kid goes do you want to
meet my family and then yeah i remember
that yeah yeah yeah
that was a good one right
anyway listen listen this is a stevie
baby show
this is stevie rubie's show um
the reason why i brought that up is
because
up dude please give me a second okay
okay i just need to
figure out what the [ __ ] is going on
right now okay
it's a variety i wanted to just bring up
the rainbow i [ __ ] know man
let me just give you a second please all
right
oh god oh [ __ ]
[Music]
just the wrong way